bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver émission un peu particulière
ce soir tu es la dernière de la saison
et pour l'occasion
on vous a préparé pas mal de surprises
on va d'abord rembobinez l'année et
revisiter les images des derniers temps
forts de ces derniers mois coronavirus
bragg dit georges floyd féminicide que
disent les mourres de l'actualité sur
l'époque que nous traversons et pour
répondre à cette question deux fils
rouges en ma compagnie
ce soir l essayiste caroline fourest et
l'éditorialiste jean michel aphatie il
est non diront et bien finalement ce
qu'ils ont retenu de cette saison et
puis tous nos chroniqueurs seront en
plateau ce soir et vous allez le voir
ils se sont tous surpassés ça vous
regarde avant la quille c'est parti on
lire
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir caroline fourest soir je corrige
d'emblée vous est aussi réalisatrice
essayiste on se souvient de soeurs
d'armes et vous publiez génération au
fond c'est il ya déjà quelques quelques
mois déjà chez grasset mais en plein
dans l'actualité toujours cette jeune
génération qui découpe un peu la société
en identité blessé et qui finit par
imposer une forme de police de la pensée
on y reviendra à bonsoir jean michel a
bâti c'est un plaisir de vous accueillir
on va revisiter l'année en votre
compagnie
la saison septembre juillet mais quel
flair vous aussi vous avez publié un
livre j'ai un accent est alors celui du
sud ouest ça j'aime quelqu'un de moi
j'ai un accent du sud ouest mais vous
aussi vous avez un accent un exemple
parisien ben on a tous un accent est
vrai on n'a pas le même mais nous avons
tous un accent mais vous dites qu'on est
un peuple tolérant dans ce livre avec
aux texans on en parlera en même temps
bon on a quand même un accent fort du
gers du sud ouest dont 10 à matignon je
ne sais pas si vous avez conseillé le
président pour ce choix mais en tout cas
non il m'a pas demandé mon avis on
l'entend fait accent on en parlera aussi
bon soir à à nos chroniqueurs raphaël
legendre
merci d'être avec nous promet l'un
dernière de la saison on va parler
économie vous êtes journaliste à
l'opinion et vous aussi vous avez
piocher dans lecture est qu au fond ce
que ce qui vous a le plus marqué enfin
bon ce soir thomas bon sens du terme à
des prêts de la rédaction de lcp vous
avez demandé vous aux députés bien ce
qu'il retenait de ces derniers mois mais
d'abord vous le savez pour les fidèles
de ça vous regarde c'est stéphane qui
ouvre toujours le bal mais stéphane
blakowski si j'ai bien compris n'est pas
vraiment en studio ce soir
pas en studio alors vraiment j'ai pas pu
venir parce qu'on s'était malentendu sur
les dates et moi je suis bien voilà je
suis déjà je vous déjà en corse voilà en
tout cas voilà une veillée tellement
d'années n'y a pas fait tout simplement
noir le film de jean pascal m'a dit ça
faisait très longtemps que j'avais pas
autant ri au cinéma très très
intelligente sa grande qualité c'est
l'auto dérision ses pairs comme hongrie
et en même temps on apprend plein de
choses
pure
les différents points de vue sur la
question
tout ça où chacun se moque un peu de
lui-même c'est souvent ce qui manque en
politique voilà un bon écran est libre
plus d'auto dérision cette année suivez
l'exemple de jean pascal joly
on va profiter bien je vois que vous
avez pris les devants quelqu'un a vu ce
film
moi je n'ai pas vu dans tellement j'en
ai entendu beaucoup de bien voilà le
racisme anti noir avec de l'autodérision
delà de la drôlerie peut-être que c'est
rien de plus puissant que c'est la
meilleure piste en parle de manque c'est
la plus et de plus grande des forces
on commence donc à rambouillet l'aktu
premiers effets mairie de septembre à
février 2020 les images marquantes que
vous allez tous les deux commenté récit
signé nathalie guy loire l'année
commence par la disparition d'un ancien
président jacques chirac 17 ce 26
septembre
et c'est toute la classe politique qui
témoigne de son émotion
un dernier hommage lui est rendu à
l'assemblée jean jacques chirac son nom
même claqué comme un slogan tandis que
tout son corps exprimer cette passion
républicaine qu'il animait depuis sa
jeunesse dans les tribunes quatre
personnalités alain juppé edith cresson
jean louis debré et patrick ollier un
adieu à leur ancien président une
journée sombre également marquée par un
nuage toxique qui apparaît juste au
dessus de la ville de rouen lusine
lubrizol est en feu et suscite
l'inquiétude des habitants qui vont
rapidement demander des comptes
l'assemblée a adopté deux chiffres 55
pour 17 contre le match terminé
le résultat est applaudi les députés
sont debout c'est le vote de la pma à
l'assemblée en première lecture le
projet de loi bioéthique est d'une
chance et même un privilège pour notre
pays
sur ces questions comme sur tant
d'autres la france est regardée la voix
de la france est écouté
féminicide ce sera le mot de cette fin
d'année
la manifestation contre les violences
faites aux femmes est un succès et
compte près de 50000 personnes à paris
on est ici pour rendre hommage à toutes
les femmes qui sont mortes sous les
coups de leur conjoint ou par ou leur ex
conjoint et qui sont mortes parce
qu'elles sont femmes en fête et c'est un
vrai problème
5 décembre 2010 9 premières
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites
j'ai pas envie de vivre dans cette
société là par exemple la retraite qu'on
le veuille ou non bah en fait moi
m'avait ce métier de la frette et une
seconde vie en fait on profite on
profite de ses petits-enfants on peut
participer à des associations
voilà on profite de en gros avoir
travaillé quand même pendant de
nombreuses années on a une seconde vie
et ce qu'on nous propose c'est pas ça
durant deux mois les transports sont
bondés et c'est aussi le grand retour
des vélos sur les routes
les gens disent pas un objet la valise
le début de l'année commencent par la
grande évasion de carlos ghosn il arrive
à s'échapper du japon de cette valise
une histoire rocambolesque qui aboutit à
la conférence de presse la plus
surréaliste de l'année je n'ai pas
échapper à la justice
j'ai fui l'injustice et la persécution
et kyushu la persécution politique
continuez monsieur le premier ministre
tout le monde garde son calme
c'est le moment où edouard philippe va
annoncer le 49 3 en pleine réforme des
retraites
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi
un fond noir un ton sobre benjamin
griveaux candidat à la mairie de paris
se met hors-jeu des municipales
j'ai décidé de retirer ma candidature à
l'élection municipale parisienne
cette décision me coûte mais mes
priorités sont très claires c'est
d'abord ma famille vous l'aurez compris
une déclaration à seulement un mois du
premier tour il ya des choses très
différentes dans ses premiers mois de la
saison caroline fourest quelle est
l'image que vous retenez quelle est
l'image dans ce qu'on vient de voir sur
laquelle vous avez envie de réagir en
premier j'ai presque envie de vous dire
que je les retiens pas parce que
d'habitude quand on fait une
rétrospective ya ces souvenirs plus ou
moins enfouis mais comme on a vécu un
événement tellement perturbateurs une
pandémie mondiale ça fait comme une
césure avec dragon ball dragon il ya un
monde d'après et donc là on
al'impression presse de regarder des
images en noir et blanc fait
et du coup c'est presque tout et tout
est fait en forme un tout j'arrive même
plus et ne ressemblent à des femmes ou
la pma j'aurais pensé
oui mais il ya des femmes pour moi je
alors ce moment je remonte aux années 90
et ça fait longtemps mais le mot
féminicide par exemple je pense que
c'est un apport dans le débat parce que
ça permet de souligner effectivement
qu'il ya des morts qui correspond pas à
des morts naturelles et qu'il faut
continuer à déconstruire ce qui mène à
ses morts ses précédents quoi peut-être
deux images quand même jacques chirac
parce que il ya un paradoxe chirac
l'action de jacques chirac n'a jamais
convaincu personne
il a toujours été mal élu à la
présidence de la république
en adepte chirac dit j'ai les français
n'aiment pas mon mari et puis quand il
meurt il ya un courant de sympathie
alors pourquoi existe-t-il ce courant de
sympathie ya sans doute beaucoup de
nostalgie
peut-être qu'on pense davantage à
l'homme qui a connu de gaulle et alors
ça nous renvoie à des années qu'on
imaginait glorieuse plutôt que l'homme
politique lui-même nous avons on leur
trouvera peut-être dans la soirée
beaucoup de problèmes avec la
construction de la mémoire en france on
a parlé et on en parlera et peut-être
que la deuxième image c'est les
retraites parce que je pense que les
retraites devrait rester en tant que
sujet d'étude comme lui l'homme des
échecs pédagogie que les plus
considérables ces dernières
est ce que la réforme était bon ou pas
chacun a une opinion mais enfin le
gouvernement l'a convaincu personne du
changement de système
les problèmes financiers de vendre
depuis longtemps pour financer la
protection sociale mais changer de
système conté différemment les points
retraite alors ça emmanuel macron et
loire philippe ont patiné complètement
dans l'explication d'une artiste
remettre sur la table aujourd'hui vous
que c'est justement cette première
partie système par points qui devraient
être discutées vous le film partenaires
je sais que c'est une erreur évidemment
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été bons le
premier toujours pourquoi il serait
devenu le deuxième et enfin on verra
bien on va on va les laisser écrire
eux-mêmes leurs films et du coup on voit
edouard philippe qui est parti qui a
quitté matignon sous les bravos mail à
l'image du 49 3 c'était pas ça mérite
d'aérer période celle là donc voilà là
aussi on avait un peu oublié toujours
les problèmes de mémoire pour revenir
une réaction sur les retraites vous êtes
d'accord avec jean michel aphatie et
c'est c'est pas franchement le moment
bien sûr qu'on n'a plus les moyens de ce
débat c'est ça qu'on est en train de
réaliser tout doucement c'est que
c'était un luxe de pouvoir débattre de
est ce qu on change de système de
retraite ou pas à partir de septembre
des faillites vont s'enchaîner des
français vont perdre des emplois en
cascade et on ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir des mouvements sociaux par
dessus on peut pas on n'a plus les
moyens tout simplement fait en même
temps crise de chômeurs ça veut dire
moins d'argent dans les caisses des
retraites permettant de compléter les
retraites c'est quand même le sujet
fondamental en france qui fait qu'on
n'arrive pas à équilibrer nos finances
publiques depuis des années on est le
pays où les gens rentrent le plus tard
sur le marché du travail où ils partent
le plus tôt c'est pour ça qu'ils manuel
macron expliqué à la mi juin qu'il
faudrait travailler pour produire plus
face à la crise notamment il pensait à
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
et cette réforme des retraites
permettait enfin de poser le sujet
financier car c'est le sujet financier
qui est important en réalité dans cette
réforme
le budget des retraites c'est quasiment
autant que le budget de l'état dans sa
totalité et ce financement n'était plus
viable
on le voyait bien donc ce qui a été
tenté
c'est une réforme qu'on dit
systémique c'est à dire simplement de la
rendre un peu plus égalitaire pour les
carrières hachées les petits carrière
ceux qui se sont retrouvés en première
ligne pendant la crise ça on peut le
remettre sur sur la table des
négociations je pense aujourd'hui les
premiers de corvée ont été mis en
lumière pendant la crise donc c'est
peut-être l'occasion le sujet financier
par contre carrière connaîtra impossible
à traiter d'autant plus qu'on attend
c'est que ça devrait vous parlez dada
oui pour les retraites le sujet
financier reste le sujet financer
l'échangé
voilà pour le coup je diffère un peu moi
je peux tout à fait rond billon s'est
changé de système qui est un problème si
vous changez de systèmes sens bien
l'expliquer vous insécurisés tout le
monde et c'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant toute la période d'explication
tout le monde a pensé qu'ils perdraient
plus tôt qu'il ne gagnerait au
changement de système et c'est en voisin
sécurité de change et franchement changé
de système vraiment il faut être fin
pédagogue pour le faire et emmanuel
macron edouard philippe andré campeau
gifles des coups de feu la confiance de
la pédagogie il faut des syndicats et un
gouvernement qui sache réellement qu'au
fabriquer des changements et des
réformes c'est tout ce que nous n'avons
pas dans ce pays
malheureusement et j'ajoute il faut
beaucoup d'argent pour chaque réforme il
faut du temps une volonté politique très
forte mais surtout beaucoup d'argent
pour qu en réalité personne ne perde
cette réforme on dit un mot sur les
femmes quand même parce que j'étais sûr
que j'allais réagir quand vous entendez
on entendait cette cette femme dire je
rends hommage à tel ou tel victime
personnes femmes
ça vous fait réagir comment parce que
vous vous saluer le mot de féminicide
qui a permis une véritable prise de
conscience alors que les violences
faites aux femmes ne date pas d'hier
et là comment vous réagissez il faut
changer notre langage commun pour
continuer encore plus loin la prise de
conscience
oui moi j'ai pas de souci est que le
fait d'interroger le langage commun et
d'essayer des fois de le rafraîchir ou
d'essayer de faire des clins d'oeil qui
nous montrent qu' on a peut-être
tendance à employer naturellement homme
et moins naturellement femme j'ai pas de
souci avec ça par contre des fois il ya
des termes qui sincèrement non seulement
n'aide pas à convainc
ce qu'on essaie de faire évoluer mais en
plus nous mettre dans des impasses
sémantique donc quand c'est le cas
j'essaie dé foi d'alerté et des moyens
d'action aussi vous avez vu évidemment
ces campagnes d'affichage et du tout ça
c'est ça contribue à l'électrochoc c'est
nécessaire sans doute je fais de trois
ans depuis la ferme it ou peut-être que
ce débat est un peu plus central dans la
société française il faut continuer ça
passe effectivement par des moyens
peut-être aussi que puisque l'action
publique est déterminante pour la prise
de conscience peut être aussi qu'il
faudrait garder les responsables
politiques en fonction parce qu'ils
connaissent les dossiers dont je n'ai
pas compris pourquoi marlène schiappa
avait été déplacée vers le ministère de
l'intérieur s'est mobilisé c'est une
histoire qu'on raconte aux enfants pages
on va on me compare une chappe à pour
surveiller gérald darmanin
c'est effectivement ce que l'elysée a
c'est à destination des enfants de la
maternelle pas de pas de gens de
citoyens tout de même adulte je ne sais
pas pourquoi on n'a pas laissé marlène
schiappa dans un secteur qu'elle
connaissait qu'elle maîtrisait ça
j'avoue que je n'ai pas bien compris
pour elle d'être aussi on ne veut pas au
ministère de la justice
quelqu'un qui a pu dire au moment de la
faire des feymen je le cite il y a
beaucoup de force qui raconte des
conneries
c'était peut-être pas la première chose
à dire j'aurais dit un mot quand même
sur gérald darmanin vous comprenez ces
manifestations qu'immédiatement après
l'annoncé nominations ont eu lieu devant
devant un ministère de l'intérieur je
comprends que des féministes soient en
colère c'est vrai que le signal
politique est quand même très léger on
sent bien que la cause des femmes qui a
été déclarée grande cause du quinquennat
est en réalité relégué derrière la crise
économique
et tous ces signaux effectivement comme
le disait jean michel aphatie changé
marlène schiappa qui est plutôt bien
réussi qui était plutôt bien débrouillé
de postes au lieu de la laisser mener
son action jusqu'au bout nommé géralda
m'annonçant qu'il est complètement
clarifiée même si ce qui lui est
reproché n'est pas aussi grave que le
disent certaines activistes
déjà eu comme quoi c'est durant ce qu'il
faut rester honnête là où là où je suis
partagé parce que je suis intellectuels
journalistes et féministe donc tout ça
en tant que famille je trouve que ce
signal politique est très mauvais mais
en tant qu'intellectuel je peux pas
m'empêcher de penser qu'on n'a pas le
droit de juger un homme à la place d'un
tribunal
quand je vois des pancartes darmanin
égale violeur c'est pas juste parce que
c'est pas ce dont il est accusé dans une
des deux affaires de l'autre affaire il
en a été quand même plutôt sorti blanchi
même si il ya une techniquement encore
une procédure en cours c'est plutôt pour
des raisons techniques
donc on parle de magie alors jusqu'à le
faire l'effet est considéré quand même
que le signal politique n'est pas bon
club d'accord avec ta wii plus tôt mais
je trouve que puisque gérald darmanin et
emmanuel macron ont pris la décision de
cette nomination alors qu'il ya une
plainte pour viol la société beau
analyser la situation telle qu'elle est
gérald darmanin est accusé on ne peut
pas sur le plan des principes dire de
quelqu'un qu'il est accusé de quoi que
ce soit qu'il ne peut pas exercer une
fonction
ça n'est pas possible déjà la politique
vit sous un régime particulier la
présomption d'innocence n'est pas
reconnue aux responsables politiques dès
qu'il ya une mise en examen
on quitte une fonction la mise en examen
n'est pas une culpabilité présence à
varier non pas du tout le jury ce qu'une
once et de restitution et ceux
d'emmanuel macron c'est à dire qui est
des enquêtes préliminaires qui ont
abouti à des sorties de gouvernement
c'est au modem mais je pense que le
modèle c'est une histoire très
particulière c'est parce que la ministre
la défense démissionne que françois
bayrou ne peut pas rester mais ça n'est
pas du tout la règle qui étaient
traditionnellement posée et qui demeure
une mise en examen
on considère que quelqu'un pour se
défendre sors de l'action publique une
accusation que c'est encore autre chose
on accuse quelqu'un mais pour le coup ou
gérald darmanin que je ne sais pas s'il
est innocent ou coupable je n'ai aucun
moyen de le savoir mais ils l'ont décidé
d'accord moi je ne l'aurais pas non mais
gérald darmanin mais ça a été décidé
comme ça donc ensuite la société placée
devant un problème le président soucis
qu'il a eu une discussion d'homme à
homme c'est l'express une expression des
produits
si on est passés les faits et on peut
considérer qu emmanuel macron se
compliquer la vie plutôt qu'il cela
simplifie mais c'est son problème
une fois que la décision est prise la
société doit répondre à cette question
est ce que quelqu'un qui est accusé doit
se voir interdire d'une fonction on ne
peut pas répondre oui à cette question
je pense qu'il faut être attentif à la
douleur des femmes et la culture de
domination masculine dans nos sociétés
nous ont rendus trop longtemps sourds à
ces douleurs donc d'une certaine manière
et que des manifestations aient lieu
c'est une bonne chose c'est la
démocratie
mais ensuite en conscience dire qu une
accusation suffit à interdire une
fonction ça me paraît être dont je veux
donc l'alimentation d'alerté sur une
démocratie d'opinion dans laquelle on
basculerait vous y êtes sensibles de la
république
attention seule la justice sait capable
de la question des droits d'égalité mais
c'est en train de devenir une forme de
démocratie dangereux c'était vrai que
c'est une c'est une démocratie très
aléatoire ou les règlements de compte
les manipulations les diffamations
peuvent tenir lieu de tribunal
et ça ça n'est pas acceptable que ce
soit pour des cas aussi grave et
terrible que le présomption de viol en
l'occurrence là plutôt d' abus de
faiblesse que d'autres cas ça révèle des
personnages qui sont peut-être pas très
sympathique mais de là à traiter comme
s'il avait été jugé condamné pour des
faits aussi graves qui sont des délits
qui sont des crimes
on doit tous gardé le sens de ces
nuances parce que ces nuances font la
qualité de notre démocratie
vous voulez nous parler des femmes aussi
mais oui la légende rapatriera l'année
2010 9 des femmes et de l'europe
deux événements majeurs christine
lagarde nommée à la présidence de la
banque centrale européenne puis ursula
von der leyen qui prend la présidence de
la commission
début décembre deux femmes qui sont
aujourd'hui au coeur de la survie nos
économies partout en europe on n'en
parle pas beaucoup en france
mais si emmanuel macron peut aujourd'hui
faire valser les milliards comme ça et
bien c'est notamment grâce à l'europe
grâce à la bce qui sous la présidence de
christine lagarde a mis en place un plan
de rachats de dettes de
350 milliards d'euros c'est à dire assez
pour éponger en réalité la dette
qu'ovide de l'ensemble des états membres
de la zone euro et ursula von der leyen
et sa commission qui ont mis en place un
plan de relance alors sous l'impulsion
franco-allemande aussi un des manuels
macro et d'un gala merkel il faut le
dire mais d'un plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros et sur les 100
milliards d'euros du plan de relance
français dont a parlé emmanuel macron
mardi lors de son interview il ya 40% 40
milliards près de 40 milliards viendront
de l'europe ça peut-être qu'on
n'entendra pas beaucoup parce qu'on aime
bien dire que faire c'est nous les
français qui sommes les plus forts mais
sans l'europe on aurait quand même 40
milliards d'euros c'est l'apathie
l'accord franco-allemand a fait la une
partout en allemagne et on en a pas
beaucoup parlé en france ces deux femmes
là qui sont vraiment au centre de la
gestion de crise on en parle peu
personne ne connaît pour cela von der
leyen nous est pour toi
la faute à nous mais bien la faute à qui
peut-être que la femme la plus
importante de cette scène c'est une
troisième femme c'est quand même la
chancelière allemande au ciel parce que
nous en france dépensé des milliards
qu'on n'a pas on y est habitué on peut
signer tous les accords de la terre on
le fait depuis longtemps d'ailleurs pour
vivre comme ça à crédit en allemagne et
la culture est très différente et il
faut une fois européenne angela merkel
qui sans doute une dirigeante
exceptionnelle on s'en rendra compte 315
favorable et une lettre quasiment 30 ans
de réélu trois fois
c'est la cinquième république n'a jamais
réélu de président de la république
jamais sur son action réélu trois fois
dans un monde où les présidents de la
république ne font plus de mandat elle a
vraiment battu ce record dans un
contexte où on sait que la politique est
périmée diffamé et relégués très très
vite avec des actes d'une générosité
incroyable en 2015 sur les réfugiés à
nos millions de réfugiés syriens le
courage extraordinaire
nous l'avons nous dirigeants français
nous fait la france les insultes et
pratiquement à ce moment-là et sa foi
européenne et dans cette affaire est
extraordinaire
vraiment nous devrions prendre exemple
sur des personnages comme ça parce que
la manière dont la chancelière et le
président français ont
gérer enfin en tout cas on nommer la
crise est très différente thomas c'est
votre tour
alors qu'est-ce que normalement votre
mission c'est de passer vos journées à
l'assemblée qu'est ce que vous avez fait
qu'est-ce que vous avez préparé mais on
a fait la même chose aujourd'hui comme
d'habitude on est à la rencontre des
députés en quittant en cause non pas
comme c'était pas nous on a demandé aux
députés ce qu'ils avaient à penser de
cette année de dresser le bilan de cette
saison alors qu'elle était l'homme où la
femme forte de cette année quelle image
ils ont retenu
eh bien écoutez si on devait garder
qu'une seule image de cette année quelle
serait-elle
pour moi c'est l'image de cet hémicycle
quasiment vide en plein de confinement
on était deux par groupes avec les
présidents de groupe des députés réunis
en urgence dans la semaine du 16 au 23
mars pour construire finalement ce
qu'étaient les prémices de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
l'assemblée était totalement fermé
déserté on avait interdiction d'y
circuler
c'était pendant des semaines et des
semaines totalement impressionnants et
ça je crois que je le garderai en
mémoire du club l'homme où la femme de
la saison selon vous c'est qui sans
conteste et d'un philippe qui qui a été
un très grand premier ministre chaque
fois il a fait face il a fait face il a
été un transparence il a expliqué je
trouve qu'il a été vraiment l'homme de
la situation et c'est lui que je
retiendrai si vous deviez garder une
image de cette année parlementaire ce
serait laquelle
l'éclatement des groupes parlementaires
parce que je crois que c'est
symptomatique de cette volonté de
réduire la place du parlement dans notre
système institutionnel finalement la
place du politique dans le
fonctionnement notre état douar philippe
arrivants la tribune de l'assemblée
après un conseil des ministres qui
étaient censés être consacrée à la
situation sanitaire qu'on nous annonçait
le 49-3 sur la réforme des retraites
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite qui à la fois les libère mais
qui est obligé de prendre un acte qu'on
pensait pas avoir à vivre soit la loi
elle se construit avec les députés
si on ne sert à rien est plutôt
favorable à ce que tous les actes et
député à résume la manière dont le
gouvernement voit et monsieur macro voix
l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire comme
un marchepied sur lequel on s'essuie ce
sont les foucades les provocations
parfois
les insultes ou les mensonges qui sont
proférées par les élus de la france
insoumise nos collègues sont peu
nombreux mais se caractérise par
justement une série de comportements qui
ont souvent provoqué un mal à l'aise je
dirais généralisée dans les travées de
l'hémicycle
selon vous qui a été l'homme ou la femme
politique de l'année cette année si je
dois parler d'une figure qui me semble
extrêmement important sur le plan
politique c'est à ça traoré qui sur la
question du racisme l'antiracisme des
violences policières est devenu une
figure politique moi je pense que c'est
elle qui cette année a montré la
justesse de ses choix
c'était anne hidalgo olivier ferrand qui
est devenu ministre dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles et dans une
situation inédite est extrêmement
compliqué et je trouve qu'il a été
extrêmement bon dans sa façon d'incarner
ce qu'est ce que devait être un ministre
de la santé à ce moment-là précis jamais
fait la btl vous surprennent ta réponse
je vous voyais aussi fort sinon c'est
terrible philippe ariès la maison qui
doit philippe notamment pour hommage à
celui qui n'est plus la wii pour
beaucoup de députés de la république en
marche qui n'ont pas encore compris
pourquoi edouard philippe
c'est à dire à désirer du coup quand on
leur offre en microbes 1 à défaut d'être
franc du collier de dire on n'a pas
compris 10 a quand même il était bien
celui là sur le 49-3 puisqu'on est sur
la chaîne parlementaire est tout de même
on critique beaucoup le 49-3 mais il
faut quand même savoir que dans les
républiques précédentes il ya eu 24
gouvernement en 12 ans de 4ème
république et 99 gouvernement en 60 52
troisième république et dont il inquiète
la vème république rationalise le
parlement quelqu'un peut déposer une
motion de censure et puis on voit si le
gouvernant la confiance ou pas ce n'est
que le premier acte d'une machine
démocratique y pense qu'il faut
peut-être un peu aller changer les
institutions en finir avec georges
providentiel qui est un chef de l'état
de grâce à la disgrâce 89 gouvernement
en 65 ans l'a dit quand même un moment
où il faut pas oublier tout ça
excusez moi juste 99 gouvernement toutes
les années 30 de l'allemagne
et les gouvernements français tombent
les uns après les autres la débâcle de
40 ha oui aux larmes en l'alerté gars et
la guerre d'algérie la quatrième on vit
une telle défiance démocratique qui va
bien falloir se poser la question de
comment faire rejouer un rôle plus
important parlement néanmoins mais je
suis d'accord avec jean michel aphatie
si c'est pour revenir en arrière sur cet
état d'impuissance déjà qu on reproche
beaucoup politique d'être impuissant et
qu'il l'est parfois face aux forces de
l'argent face à la mondialisation si
c'est pour réintroduire de l'impuissance
et de l'instabilité dans le
fonctionnement même des institutions
alors là vraiment on risque d'être battu
d'avancé
la réalité c'est que fait d'avoir un
fonctionnement assez centralisée en
france on l'a un peu vu quand même
pendant cette crise un accord on a vu
les limites face même aux résistances
administrative
c'est quelque chose qui nous permet de
piloter néanmoins mal gré mal gré groove
ans eh bien on y vient à cette crise
sanitaire puisque vous avez déjà
largement abordée mars juillet c'est
évidemment le courant n'avait riffs qui
écrase tout récit en images d'ahmed
tasiast nous sommes en guerre
toute l'action du gouvernement et du
parlement doit être désormais tournés
vers le combat contre l'épidémie mars
2020 la france déclare la guerre aux
couronnes à virus tous confinés
le premier ministre edouard philippe
annonce la fermeture des lieux non
indispensables et des commerces non
essentiels il s'agit notamment des
restaurants cafés cinémas discothèques
la france est paralysée les masques sont
rares les hôpitaux débordés
le personnel soignant à bout de souffle
[Musique]
avril 2020 leur à retenir ses 20 heures
la france des villes à l'unisson la
france rurale aussi et la france des
quartiers tous applaudissent de leur
fenêtre chaque soir à 20 heures le
personnel soignant
c'est pourquoi les applaudissent et la
crise du coc u19 agit comme un
révélateur des inégalités c'est aussi de
nouvelles solidarités
mais 2020 tous des consignes et les
mesures de confinement sont levés ce
n'est pas la fin de la pandémie
mais le début d'une nouvelle phase nous
nous réjouissons tous évidemment que le
chiffre de personnes en réanimation soit
descendue de plus de 7000 au moment du
pic à moins de 2000 aujourd'hui juin
2020 c'est une couleur le vert
lyon strasbourg bordeaux au moins une
trentaine de listes soutenues par les
verts se sont imposés lors des élections
municipales
près de deux millions de français vivent
désormais dans une commune gérée par une
liste écologiste à bordeaux le nouveau
maire n'en revient pas
[Applaudissements]
moi je portais l'écologie depuis
quelques années j'ai connu des airs
fastueuse comme ce soir j'ai connu aussi
des basses eaux
mais je me suis toujours accroché en
étant persuadé qu'un jour je serai en
phase avec les bordelais sait les
bordelais ce soir j'ai la conviction il
ya caveau l'ambiance et cas dans cette
cour du palais rohan j'ai vraiment pour
sert d'être parfaitement en phase avec
les aspirations des habitants de
bordeaux juillet 2020 et voici le
nouveau premier ministre
jean castex va devoir imprimer un style
différent de celui son prédécesseur
nouveau premier ministre nur
gouvernement des départs celui de
christophe castaner et nicole belloubet
des arrivées aussi avec roselyne
bachelot et surtout eric dupond moretti
un ténor du barreau pas très au fait des
us et coutumes dans l'exercice très
particulier des questions au
gouvernement
entre les prétoires et l'hémicycle
l'ambiance n'est vraiment pas la même
non je vous en prie le sait déjà c'est
déjà compliqué pour moi c'est là c'est
une première j'aimerais que vous me
laissiez au moins exprimer et s condé
compte les intérêts des banques
voilà on souffre en silence on souffre
en silence
voilà eric dupond moretti et le
gouvernement castex prévenu voilà
peut-être pour rebondir sur cette
dernière image eric dupond moretti qui
au fond découvre les us et coutumes des
questions au gouvernement ils sont et
son chahut g cinéma
peut-être aurait-il eu il ya deux ans
une parole très juste personne ne sera
assez fou pour me proposer d'intégrer un
gouvernement
c'était juste voilà quelqu'un l'a fait
on verra c'est un soliste parler c'est
ce que soit leur âge est ce que ce sera
un joueur d'équipé solidaire dans toutes
les circonstances on verra on va sur la
crise sanitaire
vous êtes tous les deux des observateurs
journalistes vous avez observé au fond
tout le monde a découvert pour la
première fois c'est totalement inédit
vous avez observé ceux qui nous
gouvernent qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
marqué qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
intéressé dans tout ça
s'il fallait retenir une idée c'est le
sait la priorité donnée à la vie sur
l'économie oui mais c'est pas une
évidence enfin je pense qu'il faut qu'on
réalise c'est un choix qui aurait pu ne
pas être fait et d'ailleurs qui est
compliqué à faire parce qu'il va aussi
coûter très très cher il va coûter des
vies va coûter des emplois il va coûter
beaucoup de choses ce choix là et
pourtant on l'a fait et je crois qu'on
peut quand même se satisfaire de vivre
dans des sociétés où on a un état qui
nous protège qui fait passer la vie
avant toute chose qui déclenche le
chômage partiel pour les gens tombent
qui bien sûr à des défaillances bien sûr
est en retard à des blocages
administratifs rien à regretter sur ce
choix là il ya que beaucoup un
intellectuel commence à le remettre en
cause
on n'aurait pas dû confiner dans un
milieu on pourrait faire autrement
c'est tellement facile de refaire
l'histoire après moi je pense qu'on a
pris une grande leçon d'humilité
surtout pendant ces mois là alors tout
le monde n'a pas voulu le prendre il ya
des gens qui trouvaient qu'ils avaient
toutes les idées les meilleurs tout de
suite il savait ce qu'il fallait faire à
l'instant il est plus doué que tout le
monde et puis pouvait faire tout et son
contraire est toujours avoir raison
quand même
non c'est une grande leçon d'humilité on
avance en marchant on découvre et nos
responsables politiques découvre aussi
clairement il ya des choses qui ont raté
il ya des choses qui ont quand même été
rattrapé on aurait pu avoir un président
brésilien on aurait pu avoir un
président américain on aurait pu avoir
en équateur des familles qui ont été
obligés à mettre vaille le cadavre de
leur proche dans la rue et vous j'aime
bien mélanger ce qui m'a le plus surpris
je crois j'ai pas grand chose à ajouter
à ce qu'a dit caroline mais ce qui m'a
le plus surpris c'est la défaillance de
l'autorité médicale du monde des
chercheurs une question sanitaire
particulière s'offre à nous il ya une
urgence aider à les connaître avrillon
les marolles scientifiques bien sûr vous
preniez un scientifique qui vous
disaient blanc un autre vous disais noir
la politique a dû gérer ça un aveugle
mais sans soutien de la technique est ce
que c'était pas inévitable au poteau les
scientifiques majid dans l'incertitude
et le disait
moi j'aurais envie de baptiser tout ce
monde delà de notre manque du mot de
sciences parce que l'irrationnel était
partout mais j'étais en confiance en
pensant que quand vous aviez un
professeur avec un titre à rallonge dans
un grand hôpital il vous disait quelque
chose de sensé et puis mois de février
vous dit que c'est une grippette popopop
mais vous en fait beaucoup trop combien
de médecins en dix ans sur des plateaux
et puis ensuite mais le virus sera
saisonniers l'attitude du professeur out
mondialement connu c'est une attitude
m'est insupportable de vanité qui n'a
pas aidé la société la faillite du monde
de la recherche qui a rendu le pouvoir
politique aveugle ne part et être l
enseignement majeur de cette situation
souhaitant qu'il n'y ait pas une autre
crise sanitaire parce qu'il vaut mieux
s'adresser à des forgerons à des
coiffeurs pourquoi pas des jours où
l'argent le profit des comptes a tonné
c'est la faute des scientifiques en tout
cas ils ont une lourde responsabilité
c'est sévère comme je serai peut-être
jusqu'à moins sévère que jean-michel la
vanité des professeurs de médecine ça
c'est une certitude
on le savait déjà pourri on le
pressentait vous le présentez un peu
mais là c'est apparu très clairement
néanmoins bien sûr qu'ils ont étonné
bien sûr que s'ils n'étaient sûrs de
rien parce que ce virus a déjoué
beaucoup beaucoup de raisons inconnues
est néanmoins quand même là aussi la
vitesse à laquelle on essaie de trouver
des solutions on essaie de trouver un
vaccin est quand même inédite
on n'a jamais été aussi vite néanmoins
dans la recherche des antidotes donc
c'est les deux il ya une soif de
coupables qui monte dans le pays pour
tous mais sait jamais on est à plus de
80 plaintes contre le gouvernement
contre certains ministres il ya aussi
une demande de réparation
parce que les gens ont beaucoup souffert
ont perdu des proches
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est-ce
qu'on peut on peut tenir les deux bouts
de la chaîne elles sont légitimes s'est
plainte à vos yeux
moi je déteste je déteste réflexe de
chercher des boucs émissaires des
coupables quand on ne peut pas expliquer
une malédiction c'est qu'on n'accepte
pas que des fois il ya des choses qui
oui s'impose à nous ce sont des drames
personne les a provoquées c'est très dur
parce qu'en plus c'est un drame on peut
pas dire on n'a pas vraiment d'ennemis
on a c'est un virus
donc les gens déplacent leur colère et
cherche effectivement à compenser par
des procès par des réparations en allah
et l'âme de la justice pour vous au nez
tu ne prendras c'est une femme et de
lésions des responsabilités
d'infantilisme de déplacement de
de la douleur qui n'apporte rien qui
n'apporte pas non plus ce qui
n'encourage pas le courage ni courage
politique ni le courage de dire la
vérité en italie et des avocats qui ont
sillonné dans les hôpitaux auprès des
familles en pleurs pour les encourager à
faire des procès contre personnel
médical
c'est en train de de doorns foisonner la
vie des personnels médicaux qui ont
essayé de ce bar mot là dessus parce que
il ya un besoin d'apaisement
il ya une commission d enquête
parlementaire qui fait tout un travail
d'auditions pour essayer de comprendre
la pénurie ce qui s'est passé des
dysfonctionnements sur les masses sur
des tests ça peut réconcilier ce genre
de travail là moi je croirai plus tôt la
judiciarisation est un problème
évidemment ce que vous dites est assez
juste mais en même temps dans une
démocratie des gens qui souffrent des
personnels soignants qui se sont sentis
en danger qui n'ont pas eu le matériel
pour faire faire face au virus demande
des explications et à part une démarche
judiciaire rien ne peut donner des
explications après tout que des
responsables politiques soient amenés
dans des instances diverses soit la cour
de justice de la république soit les
commissions d enquête parlementaire plus
difficilement me semble t'il devant la
justice civile on verra bien qu'il soit
amené à me donner des explications et
puis on verra ce qu'ils disent
on comprendra peut-être mieux comment a
fonctionné bien mal passé rapide
négligeant comment va fonctionner
l'appareil d'état dans le travail
d'explication sur ce qui a fonctionné et
ce qui a dysfonctionné est absolument
nécessaire et bien sûr que ça peut
apaiser les esprits et que de nouveaux
horizons c'est un devoir auprès des
citoyens
la judiciarisation de tout y compris de
personnes privées vis-à-vis du personnel
médical c'est pas la même chose que par
exemple une démarche collective du
personnel médical qui demande qu'est ce
qu'ils disent fonctionner et qu'est ce
qui les a mis en danger
bonsoir et chars vers l'est richard
wehrli vous êtes en direct via skype
chroniqueur dans cette émission bien
connu est journaliste au quotidien
suisse le temps
vous avez envie vous de vous arrêter sur
les mots on a commencé à en parler
les mots que nos dirigeants européens
ont mis sur cette crise a commencé par
mots de guerre bien sûr des manuels
macron alors effectivement 1000m il se
trouve que je suis à bruxelles pour le
sommet européen qui va s'ouvrir demain
et bien évidemment quand on regarde
cette crise le mot que l'on retient
c'est celui qu'on a vu emmanuel macron
prononcer tout à l'heure le mot de
guerre
une guerre contre un ennemi invisible
qui est par définition l'ennemi le plus
difficile à vaincre
alors j'ai regardé ce que les autres
dirigeants européens avaient dit angela
merkel dont on parlait tout à l'heure
elle s'était contenté de parler de plus
grand défi depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale et elle avait conjuré les
allemands prenaient ce virus au sérieux
avait-elle dit giuseppe konté vitalien
lui il avait simplement dit je reste
chez moi
nous devons tous faire quelque chose
renoncer à quelque chose pour sauver
l'italie ça c'était pour justifier le
confinement généraliser ce passage n'a
repêché par l'expression de guerre des
manèges macro un certain déraillement
français c'était quand même très risqué
surtout 80 ans après la débâcle de 1940
or ce qu'on a vu pendant cette épidémie
coronavirus c'est quand même un problème
de masques de tests de coordination et
cetera alors il n'y a t'il pas la
tentation toujours française d'utiliser
des grands mots notamment de la part d'
emmanuel macron la tentation au fond de
donner des cours plutôt que d'être à
côté des gens et de simplement plaidé
pour des simples mesures de terrain je
ne me demande
rétrospectivement s'il n'aurait pas
mieux valu dès le départ
parler de résistance ou bien d'efforts
collectifs parce qu'après tout dans
cette période de confinement ce dont on
avait besoin ce n'est pas d'une guerre
c'était plutôt d'une paix sociale
merci beaucoup restèrent vous êtes
d'accord mais on parle pas aux français
comme on parle aux allemands on est pas
on n'a pas la même culture ni des mots
et surtout les appels à la guerre c'est
sûr que pourquoi parce que c'est plus
compliqué bon on est moins s'ils n'ont
pas ce qu'on a normalement un peuple qui
aime les grands mots on est on est un
peu de grandes passions et quand on a
des grands défis et généralement on nous
parle avec des grands mots néanmoins
dans ce cas là je suis pas loin d'être
d'accord c'était pas le ton est
d'ailleurs le président de la république
la rectifier il s'en est aperçu en cours
de wayne c'est à dire qu'après quelques
semaines de confinement quand tout le
monde avait quand même fait beaucoup
d'efforts étaient quand même un peu en
train de plonger en termes de déprime
vouloir réactiver l'idée qu'on était en
guerre que tout le monde devait
continuer et c'est ça ne marchait pas on
avait besoin d'un accompagnement là
effectivement on avait besoin d'une
parle transparente et rassurantes donc
il a changé de cap en cours de route et
il a eu raison que vous allez rebondir
mais j'aime enquête non pas parce que je
n'ai pas présenté nos chroniqueurs qui
vous écoutent attentivement françois
durpaire bienvenus
chronique américaine dans un instant
vous fait vivre le feuilleton haletant
de cette campagne américaine et camille
saféris 1 qui se partagent un apéro
hebdomadaire avec des députés pour nous
les faire mieux connaître
en tout cas différemment la chronique à
l'appel de richard berry était
intéressante à écouter parce que
emmanuel macron à parler du mot guerre
mais en gala merkel parle du plus grand
défi depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
ils sont pas très très loin l'un de
l'autre
et puis qui sait pas compter il faut
sauver l'italie
écoutez si on en est là quand même c'est
que la situation est sérieuse et richard
werly conseiller ou aurait conseillé à
emmanuel macron de parler plutôt de
résistance et s'il ya bien quelque chose
en france aussi à la guerre c'est la
résistance donc c'était pas si loin que
ça bien sûr que c'est un peu outré la
guerre la guerre il répétait doux soir
il s'est fait un peuple et cette fois ci
l'effet recherché mais nous faire sans
danger
le virus mais un pays en danger donc on
peut appeler ça comme on veut mais ça
ressemble quand même ring guerre et en
même temps car l'offre est heureusement
n'avions pas de populiste au pouvoir
parce que quand on regarde la manière
dont ils ont géré les choses ça fait
froid dans le dos vous aviez envie de
revenir là dessus on vous a préparé
quelques images boris johnson qui se
félicite de serrer des mains en pleine
crise du coc vide donald trump qui
suggère des injections de désinfectant
ou encore jaillir bol sonar ou le
président brésilien qui après avoir pris
pas mal de bain de foule a fini par
contracté le virus il ya eu un populisme
au fond quoi irresponsable surréaliste
mais c'est terrible dire que vivre une
pandémie on n'y peut rien on voulait on
pouvait difficilement y échapper mais
par contre avoir en plus d'une pandémie
mondiale des irresponsables pareil des
grands enfants narcissique complètement
incompétent qui vont jusqu'à faire des
bains de foule pour montrer qu'il faut
pas avoir peur que c'est super de se
contaminer ses terribles mois ccc
finalement moi ça m'a presque plus
angoissés que le virus le film et
comment on a pu laisser le monde entre
les mains de ces gens là et comment on
va sortir parce qu on est tous
interconnectés
alors évidemment on peut pas voter ni
aux états unis ni au brésil mais les
votes qui se passe aux etats unis ont de
l'impact sur nous notamment kankankan
donald trump a expliqué qu'il fallait
boire de l'eau de javel il n'a pas
expliqué comme ça évidemment appris s'en
sort toujours par une pirouette m'enfin
il a fait une des conférences de presse
pendant toute cette période
continue qui sont surréalistes et quand
tout le monde vous expliquer quand il a
été élu c'est pas grave ça va rien
changer c'est juste un clown oui mais un
clown qui a le pouvoir quand le monde
prend cette direction il peut prendre
cette direction à tout moment le monde
c'est grave en fait c'est pas drôle en
fait est grave et commence j'étais bien
commencé on verra la suite à al payer
donald trump 1 il est aux abois dans les
sondages il est même elle même fini par
accepter de le porter ce fichu masque
soit oui c'est ça alors on peut
évidemment décliné en disant c'est du
populisme sanitaire quand il s'adresse
aux américains et qui dit moi en fait on
m'a dit j'ai entendu les témoignages
disent que l'hydroxyde chloroquine ça
marche mieux que ce que dit faux sic et
pourtant le médecin en chef à la maison
blanche qui donc c'est la première chose
c'est évidemment le caractère anti
science de tout cela il ya la recherche
de boucs émissaires
dès le départ ce virus il n'est pas
américain il n'est pas européen il est
chinois china vaille russe
et puis ça se termine avec le crunch
furieuse parce que les américains
évidemment à chercher un autre bouc
émissaire ils se disent c'est donald
trump qui est responsable de tout cela
il avait du temps pour préparer et il
n'a pas préparé
et puis l'outrance du mot guerre on le
retrouve dans la bouche de donald trump
très rapidement quand il se rend compte
qu'ils perdent du temps il utilise le
mot guerre sauf que ça se retourne
contre lui parce que quand les
américains constatent qu'il ya plus de
morts deux fois plus qu'au vietnam et
ils se disent c'est comme au vietnam
c'est un enlisement
parce qu'il ya une première vague qui se
prolongent comment on sort de la guerre
ça se passe quand l'armistice et il sera
pas le du vietnam ou où ça a pris du
temps et où on a mal compris les choses
et aujourd'hui il ya des états notamment
pierce à ce qu'ils ont accompli leur
dire si ce n'est pas dépassé le pic
n'est pas dépassé la courbe rafa je suis
tu dois partir
le dernier rapport est assez inquiétant
disant 200000 morts en plus d'ici
novembre
peut-être c'est pas certains évidemment
mais ça fait partie des hypothèses
allez on va retrouver alex taylor
maintenant on continue la tournée des
chroniqueurs alex notre franco
britannique préféré qui lui aussi avait
envie de revenir sur sur cette crise
sanitaire qu'est ce qu'il a trouvé comme
image marquante
alex oui je vais vous en boucher un coin
mais rien car j'ai passé l'année à taper
sur mon pays d'origine en tout cas sur
son actuel dirigeant et sa bande préc
site
mais là c'est un moment où j'étais fier
il s'agit d'une toute petite phrase
toute simple prononcé par la reine dans
son discours en plein milieu du
confinement qu'omid wii ou bwin a french
and will be with affirme le jeune will
meet again we will meet again
nous allons nous retrouver il n'y avait
qu'elle pour dire ça ça parle à chaque
britannique à c'était la chanson de la
seconde guerre mondiale santé par la
chanteuse r aline qui a incarné l'espoir
des britanniques bombardé par le blitz
nous allons retrouver dans nos mers dans
nos veines le sait où ni quand vous
savez myriam lui n'est plus fière que
moi d'être désormais citoyen français
j'ai vibré marty pour la marseillaise je
ne suis même pas particulièrement
monarchiste mais la ve les circonstances
le confinement
il n'y avait qu'elle qui était sur le
balcon de buckingham en 45 qu'ils
pouvaient trouver les mots justes pour
parler si profondément à l'âme de tout
un peuple que dis-je peut-être de tout
un monde
voilà un oiseau mouche j'étais vraiment
ému un moi aussi je suis mauve quand je
vous écoute alex merci décidément mais
que de femmes dans cette crise qui ont
joué un rôle fondamental
oui oui en tout cas oui vous avez raison
vous avez raison il ya beaucoup de
femmes et aujourd'hui les élections
municipales ont montré aussi en france
la relation entre le pouvoir et les
femmes n'est plus questionné par les
citoyens si elle a été auparavant il
reste encore des progrès à faire
emmanuel macron avait dit qu'il
nommerait une femme premier ministre
encore attendre les jours de jean castex
seront moins longue qu'il met dans le
juge lors il y aura de l'usiné le jour
il nommera une femme premier ministre
avec un accent alors là
là tout ira bien draps des livres
c'était pour la crise sanitaire parce
que elle a tout écrasé sur la planète et
dans les médias jusqu'à une date jusqu'à
mai de melgven et des manifestations
racistes anti noirs antiraciste
évidemment et voilà cette image on va
vouloir montrer parce qu'elle est très
dur il s'agit évidemment de jazz floyd
john floyd
vous le voyez immobilisé par un policier
qui lui maintient le genou sur la nuque
je ne peux pas respirer dit il et john
floyd va mourir asphyxié à partir de là
on ne parle presque plus que de ça on
parle encore de la crise sanitaire bien
sûr est-ce que c'est justifié
après tout il ya eu énormément d'atroces
assassinats de policiers
évidement aux états unis mais c'est
celui là qui fait basculer
vous l'avez compris d'abord je crois que
cette image elle n'a parlé à tout le
monde parce que on est témoin d'un
policier qui se sait filmer qui en toute
impunité continuent à tuer un citoyen
qui ne se débat pas qui ne cherche pas à
fuir qui est en train d'appeler sa mère
et qui est en train de manquer d'oxygène
et je pense que cette phrase je ne peux
pas respirer
elle a parlé à tout le monde parce que
c'était un moment où la planète et est
en train d'asphyxier on était sous des
masques et donc il ya eu une connexion
universelle qui s'est fait avec sept
aces fixie de georges floyd et ça c'est
le bon côté de cette histoire parce que
dans toutes les pandémies mondiales
après la psd d'autres généralement c'est
pas l'anti racisme qui flambe un c'est
plutôt le racisme au mur les gens et on
cherche des boucs émissaires
ceci dit cette histoire n'est pas
terminée ce qui m'inquiète plus au
milieu de cette cette prise de
conscience mondiale qui est sublime
c'est qui on va tous les tiraillements
de l'antiracisme et que là toutes les
leçons n'ont pas été tirées je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui comprennent pas ou
qui mesurent pas assez dans quel monde
on est donald trump baisse dans les
sondages mais il peut encore repasser
notamment si une certaine façon de
défendre l'égalité dérape on a vu des
choses hallucinantes survient
généralement avant le français est par
exemple on a vu des étudiants californie
et à oxford demandé à ce que des
étudiants noirs ne passent pas leurs
examens de fin d'année
parce que georges floyd et emi
vous imaginez si tout le monde se met à
demander à passer ses examens de fin
d'année chaque fois qu'il ya un mort en
syrie en irak ou ailleurs ça n'a aucun
sens et ça pourrait paraître ridicule
comme ça sauf que donald trump qu'il a
un conseiller secret qui est en train de
revenir derrière lui steve annan qui est
loin d'être un idiot et qui sait
exactement ce qu'il peut faire de ce
genre de chose quand il fait ses
discours et tous ses discours de
campagne
il évite de parler du coc vide il n'a
qu'à parler de tous les exemples absurde
de là quand celle culture de la gauche
américaine qui passe son temps en ce
moment a essayé de demander la censure
d'écrivains ou affo love déboulonner des
statuts et rien qu'avec ça il peut
sauver sa campagne
or il faut qu'on sache ce qu'on veut si
on veut le racisme pour le coup système
si on veut que le racisme face système
il faut continuer à faire n'importe quoi
a ridiculisé l'antiracisme et donald
trump repassera et peut-être même qu'en
europe l'extrême droite finira par
passer
je les vois tu prends soin oui j'ai même
fait bien sûr pourquoi parce que il ya
une opinion américaine qui
majoritairement a basculé équine opinion
blanche américaine pour la première fois
de l'histoire américaine
évidemment j'entends mais je considère
que c'est très marginal voyez d'ailleurs
joe biden ne reprend pas cette
thématique ne reprend pas la thématique
des réparations et il est sur l'économie
il a compris qu mais il est aussi sur la
fracture raciale pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui 54% des blancs américains
disent parmi les trois problèmes
s'il ya la question raciale ont pensé
que l'élection d'un noir allaient
changer des choses mais il ya vraiment
ça n'est pas ce soit qu'on soit d'accord
un jour il n'est pas question de nier la
question raciste qu'est ce que veut le
cas c'est parce que les blancs s'en
saisissent et ça c'est black line matin
au sein mais ça c'est très bien ça
personne n'est condamné le mouvement
blanc et universal antiraciste on est
absolument tous pour c'est nécessaire et
ça doit et ça ça part dans sa campagne
là on parle d aix et liberticide menée
contre des artistes contre la culture
qui est une forme de vraiment de
d'intimidation intellectuelle qui
développe et qu'il était en tête aux
etats unis quand on parle de statut dans
le sud des états unis vous connaissez
alors celui des états unis derrière vous
avez des suprémacistes blancs quittent
la salle montagne ne sont pas du tout
qui ne
me parle qu'avec lancement il ya eu les
états unis le déboulonnage aller parce
que c'est important et là où france je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est pas la
même chose d'avoir un débat sur des
statues de négriers dans la seule seul
fait d'armes est d'avoir fait de
l'argent sur la traite que d'avoir des
débats qu'on a chez nous victor
schoelcher a été déboulonnée où on
taille milliards chine c'est pas la même
chose que justement jean michel aphatie
vous voulez revenir vous savez
déboulonnage de statuer notamment sur
une image vous allez nous là nous la
commenter c'est tout près tout près
d'ici et beaucoup de manifestations
d'ailleurs dans le monde entier on a vu
des statuts davis et déboulonné et puis
juste à côté du palais bourbon donc de
la peinture rouge le statut colbert pour
cadrer quand même le débat puisque dans
les sociétés occidentales il ya des gens
qui eux bien sûr le fait est loin de
1150 les héritiers ont une sensibilité
particulière à la question de
l'esclavagé ou bien la question de la
colonisation dans le sillage du meurtre
de george floyd ils nous ont amenés à
nous questionner sur l'histoire comment
écrivons-nous l'histoire et comment on
fabrique on nous la mémoire de
l'histoire quand il y a dans certaines
vide des maréchaux des généraux qui ont
été associés à des opérations de
colonisation sanglante
nos prières qui ont choqué les
contemporains eh bien on peut se
demander pourquoi ces statues demain
encore vous savez que la ville de lille
avait été l'objet le théâtre de
manifestations contre la statue du
maréchal gallieni et ou du général
galliéni et comme il est combattants de
la première guerre mondiale la
municipalité ne veut pas bouger de cette
statue mais en 2013
la ville de lille a débaptisé une rue la
rue canrobert d'un général qui en
algérie a été un assassin
donc on voit bien que la fabrication de
la mémoire étonnant que je suis en
commun qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est parce
que y'a colbert et puis vous avez un
autre combat personnel ont joué votre
compte twitter c'est le message du
sommet on va rester sur coole berkshire
ce cover commerce pour expliquer mais
les des finances ou 14 à mener sur
quelque chose
voilà de l'histoire alors on va pas
réécrire l'histoire parce qu'on ne l'a
pas écrite l'histoire de colbert
colbert quand il meurt en 1683 garde
royale protège l'église saint-eustache
on enterre colbert de nuit pourquoi
parce que les gilet jaune de l'époque
veulent faire un sort aux cercueils de
colbert parce que colbert pendant 20 ans
il les a matraqué d'impôts et le peuple
de paris quand colbert mer ils montrent
une chanson à l'attention de dieu il a
pillé paris il va piller le paradis est
alors on donne un salon colbert la
statue j'en sais trop rien en fait
mais en salon à colbert l'assemblée
nationale dans sa sagesse a donné des
noms de musiciens ou de peintre à ces
salons sauf d'un colbert bon colbert qui
a pillé les caisses du roi lesquels
n'étaient rappelons le les zones noires
expliqué est ce que mon or exactement
quand on donne le nom de d'une aile
colbert à bercy le grand architecte de
l'économie ou le pilleur du trésor de
l'état
on se pose cette règle vaut il ya trop
d'ambiguïtés nationale aimerait beaucoup
et en achetant les équations lui qui
fait qu'on ne doit pas réviser
l'histoire mais bien sûr qu'il faut fait
toujours questionner l'histoire est bien
sûr ça évidemment qu'il faut toujours
question histoire évidemment que la
représentation statuesque et les plaques
dans l'espace public dise quelque chose
d'aujourd'hui et de notre regard sur
hyères et que bien sûr ce regard doit
être en permanence renouveler qu'on
puisse faire de nouvelles statues de
nouvelles plates par exemple peut être
un peu plus de femmes qu'on renouvelle
ce regard c'est une évidence qui doit
décider les genres de justement le
couple qui décide le curseur le général
bugeaud sa deuxième équipe française
c'est c'est vraiment nous allons lotois
cette valve expliqué chu bon ça ne va
pas être plus compliquée la doua est une
délibération citoyenne où on pose le
pour le contre on doit accepter quand
même qu'il y ait surtout si on parle des
siècles passés
des fois des parts d'ombré et que
néanmoins il existe des grands hommes
qui ont des pardons parce que tous sont
non pardon moi si je commence à vouloir
déboulonner tous les gens qui ont
étaient homophobes et sexistes alors
excusez moi il restera plus personne en
aura des numéros colbert sa taille son
mari
le pillage des biens publics non tout
est intéressant de dire que d'abord il
ya pas qu un pardon il y en a plusieurs
qu'elle commence à être très lourdes et
qu'effectivement contre fait le bilan
peut-être que c'est là pardon qui
l'emportent si la part dont blanc porte
peut-être qu'effectivement on peut
envisager hautes chalais en or ce que tu
écoutes juste et la diva le temps presse
alors rapidement perdu dans cette maison
il faudrait pas contre ap certains
chronique en juin 1845 un débat sur l'
asphyxie des algériennes par bugeaud
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas d'
anachronisme a jeté un regard négatif
sur le maréchal bugeaud
il a effrayé ses contemporains et qu'il
est une avenue à paris et qu'une école
maternelle bugeaud il en existe deux en
france une école maternelle bugeaud à
brest les habitants de brest ont fait
une pétition en 1985 contre cette école
là il nous en sommes toujours là nous
avons le message est passé
nous avons quelque chose
d'indécrottables en nous l'histoire de
france on ne peut plus la touche et vous
ouvrez la boîte de pandore et vous êtes
là pour que je suis heureux d'avoir pu
le faire français doutent de ses effets
ça doit quand débarrassions néanmoins je
voudrais qu'on termine à pâques on
termine mais qu'on avance a avec vous
sur une sur une bonne nouvelle sur 7 sur
ses saisons parce que sur cette saison
on avait fait qu'on peut le dire il ya
réjouir aussi vous avez envie de ne pas
les écouter on était en plein oui on
était en plein coït 19 aux états unis
alors c'est un événement qui pourra se
lire de différentes manières je parle de
spe 6 du retour dans l'espace mais pour
les enfants du monde entier
il y en avait peut-être en france à
peut-être aux états unis n'avaient
peut-être partout ils ont vu ces images
là vraiment avec la même lumière dans
les yeux au moment de la lune et la lune
c'était aussi des enjeux géopolitiques
donc évidemment c'est ce départ dans
l'espace c'est
une nouvelle ère dans la conquête de
l'espace alors on va dire à quoi ça sert
les américains retourne dans l'espace
édition allait déjà plusieurs fois mais
là c'est particulier l'ananas loue son
siège donc ça veut dire que si la nasa
loup le siège tout le monde peut louer
le siège et l'idée évidemment le rêve
c'est que cette conquête de l'espace et
se passe comme la conquête c'est comme
l'aéronautique
c'est à dire première phase c'est les
états c'est la guerre ça sert à faire la
guerre deuxième chose on y envoie les
riches ce qui peut être dans cinq ans
six ans tom cruise ils ont tous déjà
lors leur place et puis dans 20 ans 25
ans trente ans nous tous et ça qui fait
rêver pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas moi
je suis candidate
en tout cas merci merci beaucoup
françois en termine avec vous camille
alors camille saféris nous a préparé un
petit best-of parce qu'il faut savoir
que il sait mieux que personne au fond
tirer le fil d'une conversation
absolument incroyable avec les députés
et nous les fait découvrir autrement qu
est ce que vous avez retenu
je voudrais avant toute chose qu'on a
une petite pensée ce soir pour un député
qui nous a quittés qui s'appelait jean
françois cesarini qui avait 49 ans qui
est mort au début du début du
confinement peut pas s'en sont sans
aucun rapport avec avec la copine ça a
été mon premier invité voilà il ya
quelques images il était très très sympa
très rigolo très apprécié c'était aussi
un comédien un poète
c'était un peu le beau gosse de
l'assemblée on avait bien rigolé voilà
c'est le premier il a essuyé les plâtres
et voilà je voulais qu'on ait une pensée
pour lui se souvient très bien et puis
sinon bah oui je vous ai préparé un
petit best-of parce que c'est vrai que
les députés sont quand même assez
surprenant
en général ils sont drôles oui ils
peuvent être drôles
ça témoigne parfois passionnés parfois
passionnants parfois les deux ils ont
parfois un peu du mal à sortir de la
langue de bois de la rhétorique comme ça
enfin peu difficile mais il ya des vrais
gens quand même avec des vraies
histoires avec un passé avec souvent une
vocation peut-être un peu contrarié par
tout aussi mais ils ont quand même
vraiment joué le jeu ils sont prêtés aux
généraux
et remercie pour ça voilà la langue de
bois vous avez pris des cours pas du
tout donc la langue de bois c'est
naturel j'ai appris non c'est pas
naturel
vous savez très bien que s'il ya une
question qui est dérangeant c'est en
fonction de la manière dont la réponse
pourrait être utilisés pour piéger celui
à qui elle a été posée j'ai rien compris
est ce que le tailleur et de droite je
crois pas parce qu'il m'arrive d'en
porter comme il m'arrive de porter des
jeans c'est pour ça que c'est bien
d'être sur marche c'est en même temps
cette envie de m'étendre jim turley
l'origine c'était envie d'être en
tailleur très strictes tu peux le faire
il ya du verre vide un peu chez vous on
vous l'a jamais dit une fois oui sur le
sort et ouais y'a du spock un peu en
haut c'était 2022
giscard la barre ça pourrait très chaud
est aux normes et je suis pas sûr que ce
soit très forte savait pouvoir ressentir
le dis parce que je n'entrais pas de
demande
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup de
déguisements et je n'aimais pas pour
l'assemblée nationale si vous m'invitez
chez vous pour halloween pour une ferme
bal costumé pour votre anniversaire pour
le nouvel an et je lis et de grandes
chances que je me déguise chez moi dans
l'état tient un petit appareil photo
comme ça attendez je vous ai tous les
deux comme ça serait pas mal
elles sont pas mal les ouailles et celle
avantages du grand temps alors moi
j'adore la brocante
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de vieilleries à
la fois parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
manifestations locales
j'adore jardinier m'occuper de mes
poules et vous avez des poules je sais
pas combien de poule
car des rousses des poules pondeuses et
il faut mettre les oeufs la veille ou
l'avant-veille
avec les truffes déjà la truffe parfume
les e71 barre on a bien sûr un parti
officiel mon bureau ce travail et donc
on boit petit coup 1 et le soir pareil
et j'aime beaucoup mais c'est vrai si si
si c'est comme le prof nous avez dit
dans votre classe y en aura au moins un
qui sera député mais je pense qu'il
devait il dire à toutes ses classes
alors vous faites ça avant de parler à
l'assemblée merci vous avez détendu
merci aura peut être de droite je pense
yarham de droit à toi moi je suis absent
et familiales voilà est-ce quelque chose
qui en politique est aussi puissant que
l'évocation la force tellurique poétique
de l'eau de vie de mirabelle
non mais il ne tiendra qu'à vous
beaussire d'être aussi grand que moi lui
reparti le chien quitter les bois vous
ferez bien
karkwa points franchis paix tout à la
pointe de l'épée
suivez moi vous aurez un bien meilleur
destin et bien c'est formidable vous
revenez l'année prochaine les et camille
merci françois je renvoie à la lecture
de votre les prix france télé on a de la
chance de vous avoir parmi nous histoire
mondiale du bonheur ça fait du bien
ch et cherche midi génération au fond
c'est caroline fourest grâce à ça j'ai
un accent est alors un cc michel lafon
je prends allers les 30 secondes qui me
reste on est déjà très en retard pour
remercier
évidemment toutes les équipes dès le cp
pour cette très belle émission
elles se sont données à fond la
rédaction évidemment au premier chef la
production john on compte sur toi
l'année prochaine aux documentalistes
nos graphistes le trafic
l'antenne et puis évidemment vous les
voyez c'est toute la régie
ils sont fondamentaux rire vous
découvrez qui vous découvrez là vous
découvrez deux personnes que j'aime
énormément et qui vont partir alors à
gauche vous avez sylvain poulet c'est
mon programmateur préféré qui s'est
arraché cette année pour voilà nous fait
revenir je suis très ému et les
meilleurs invités 1 et en témoigne
d'ailleurs ce plateau encore ce soir
pour la dernière
et puis mon fabrice mon fabrice qui s'en
va c'est pas simple de deux kits et qui
va aller vers d'autres aventures fabrice
pierrot c'est le producteur c'est le
rédacteur en chef de cette émission il a
mis sa patte il a tout transformé il a
ouvert les fenêtres et la pousser les
murs et tout ça pour le mieux de cette
émission merci à vous belle et et
profitez bien celle à qui bones
[Musique]